ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 7a
und 7b erste beratung des von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur erhöhung des schutzes
durch den gesetzlichen mindestlohn und
zu änderungen im bereich die
geringfügigen beschäftigung sowie
beratung des antrags der fraktion die
linke mit dem titel ausweitung der
minijobs konterkariert erhöhung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns für die
aussprache wurde eine dauer von 68
minuten beschlossen
bitte die kolleginnen kollegen den
sitzplatz wechsel doch möglichst zügig
vorzunehmen das geht auch für die
fraktionen von fdp und bündnis 90 die
grünen
ja zwölf euro mindestlohn bald soll aus
dem zentralen wahlkampfversprechen des
kanzlers realität werden auch die grenze
für mini-jobs wird angehoben hierfür hat
die bundesregierung den entwurf eines
mindestlohn erhöhungs gesetzes vorgelegt
der nun in erster lesung beraten wird
und auch die linke hat den antrag
eingebracht und als erster redet der
bundesarbeits und sozialminister
hubertus heil
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen und kommenden sonntag ist
der tag der arbeit der erste mai ein
feiertag mit wirklich stolz tradition
ein tag auf den ich mich als
arbeitsminister freude aber auch ganz
persönlich ein tag mit großer tradition
aber es geht eben auch um hochaktuelle
themen sonntag werden viele millionen
menschen auf der welt auf die straße
gehen für werte wie frieden für freiheit
für soziale gerechtigkeit und für
solidarität am ersten mal geht es
natürlich aber auch immer wieder um den
wert und die würde der arbeit es geht
darum meine damen und herren das
millionen von arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer das bekommen was ihnen
zusteht anständige arbeitsbedingungen
und eben auch faire löhne und dazu
gehört auch die erhöhung des
mindestlohns
präsident meine damen und herren wir
sind heute hier um eine zusage
einzulösen ein versprechen mehr respekt
auch dafür ist diese bundesregierung
angetreten mehr respekt für diejenigen
die tag für tag dafür sorgen dass der
laden läuft die großes leisten und das
oftmals für kleines geld die rede ist
ganz konkret von verkäuferin einer
bäckerei arbeiten von denjenigen die als
helferin tate von der landwirtschaft
tätig sind oder auch von friseurinnen
und meine damen und herren es sind
gerade diese menschen
mit kleineren und normalen einkommen die
sich schon während der pandemie den
letzten zwei jahren große sorgen gemacht
haben und jetzt besonders beunruhigt
sind angesichts von steigenden preisen
die bundesregierung hat deswegen dafür
gesorgt dass besonders diese menschen in
der jetzigen krise entlastet werden
deswegen haben wir entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht um härten abzufedern
wir entlasten damit zum beispiel eine
familie mit normalem einkommen
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer mit zwei
kinder beide eltern berufstätig
um mehr als 950 euro in diesem jahr
hinzu kommen individuelle entlastungen
für bahnstrom bei kraftstoffen beim
nahverkehr dass meine damen und herren
ist politik für soziale stabilität in
unserem land
das kann nicht sein
dass gerade die menschen mit kleinen
einkommen die größten lasten tragen sie
haben und sie brauchen solidarität
präsident meine damen und herren mehr
respekt bedeutet auch dass wir gerade
jetzt den gesetzentwurf zur erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf den weg bringen die
evaluation also die untersuchung des
bestehenden mindestlohns aus dem jahre
2020 hat uns zwei klare botschaften auf
den weg gegeben
erstens die einführung des mindestlohns
ist ein erfolgsmodell es hat
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit
gesichert und höhere löhne für rund vier
millionen menschen schaffen ich kann
mich übrigens an die ideologischen
debatten aus der damaligen zeit um die
einführung des mindestlohns noch sehr
lebhaft erinnern damals waren manche auf
den plan der untergang der sozialen
marktwirtschaft an die wand gemalt haben
interessanterweise sind dass auch
diejenigen die sich jetzt wieder zu wort
melden insofern sollten sie ihre eigenen
worte erinnern die wahrheit ist das
gegenteil ist richtig die einführung des
mindestlohns war und ist ein
sozialpolitischer meilenstein und ich
will mich auch heute noch dafür bedanken
dass meine amtsvorgängerin andrea nahles
das damals durchgesetzt
unser ziel muss es doch in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft sein dass die
die vollzeit arbeiten auch davon leben
können und die zweite botschaft dieser
evaluation aus dem jahre 2020 war wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sich der
mindestlohn angemessen weiterentwickelt
das ist sozialpolitisch geboten es ist
sozialstaatlich geboten auch angesichts
wie gesagt der aktuellen
preisentwicklung damit millionen von
menschen den anschluss an die arbeiten
damit in diesem land nicht verlieren die
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer ist es
deshalb wichtig dass die erhöhung des
mindestlohns jetzt kommt und auch
schnell kommt sogleich allerdings
fordern arbeitgeber und ihre verbände
dass es einen hinreichenden vorlauf
dafür gibt ich und die bundesregierung
sind überzeugt dass mit dem
inkrafttreten zum ersten oktober 2022
wie ein fairer und auch schon der
interessenausgleich gelungen ist wenn
klar ist dass die weiterentwicklung des
mindestlohns als instrument des
sozialstaates eine aufgabe des
gesetzgebers ist
gleichzeitig finde ich betonen dass das
bewährte system der
sozialpartnerschaftlich verhandelten
mindestlöhne damit nicht grundsätzlich
in frage gestellt wird wir wollen es nur
insofern anpassen wo das erforderlich
ist um für angemessenen mindestschutz
für arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer zu
sorgen da es auch
dass die mindestlohn kommission in
zukunft weitere anpassungen übernehmen
wird und das heißt dass damit auch die
sozialpartner rinn und sozialpartner
eingebunden sind und natürlich meine
damen und herren ist der mindestlohn
auch nach dieser erhöhung immer nur eine
absolute lohnuntergrenze
die ist notwendig und zwölf euro das ist
ungefähr 60 prozent des mittleren
einkommens in deutschland so eine
vernünftige lohnuntergrenzen aber ich
sage auch uns als bundesregierung reicht
das nicht aus wir wollen wieder mehr
tarifbindung in deutschland und dafür
werden wir auch anreize setzen
deshalb nicht oder ist kein
koalitionsvertrag verankert und
vereinbart haben dass beispielsweise
öffentliche aufträge des bundes
zukünftig nur an die unternehmen gehen
sollen die nach tarif bezahlen meine
damen und herren das ist die stadträte
anreize setzen
mit diesem gesetzentwurf sorgen wir
dafür dass der mindestlohn zum ersten
oktober 2022 also auf 12 euro steigt wer
vollzeit dann zumindest und arbeitet
verdient bisher brutto rund 1700 euro
dann rund 2100 euro und ich will noch
mal sagen wer davon vor allen dingen
profitiert millionen von menschen vor
allen dingen frauen die haben
arbeitsmarkt arbeiten den laden am
laufen halten und auch sehr viele
beschäftigte in ostdeutschland das ist
eine lohnerhöhung von rund 22 prozent
das haben wir versprochen und wir machen
das meine damen
und ich sage das gerade in diesen zeiten
wir haben am heutigen vormittag zu recht
über frieden und über äußere sicherheit
gesprochen aber das ist kein gegensatz
zu sozialer stabilität im inneren im
gegenteil meine damen und herren äußere
sicherheit und innerer sozialer frieden
sind zwei seiten einer medaille
deshalb geht es nicht um krisen
management oder sozialen fortschritt wir
müssen beides schaffen in deutschland
unser sozialstaat meine damen und herren
und auch in die soziale marktwirtschaft
sind stark der sozialstaat sorgt für
verlässlichen schutz und
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt gerade
auch in zeiten der krise und unser ziel
und dafür leistet die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 auf einen wichtigen
beitrag ist und bleibt ein starkes und
ein faires deutschland herzlichen dank
der zuständige bundesarbeitsminister hat
die einführung des mindestlohnes durch
seine vorgängerin andrea nahles als
meilenstein gelobt
sozialpartnerschaftlich verhandelte
mindestlöhne wolle man nicht ausbremsen
man wolle nur der für einen
mindestschutz besorgen die arbeitgeber
sind der meinung sie lehnen staatliche
lohnfestsetzung ab und wollen eventuell
gegen dagegen klagen stephan stracke der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union
unter führung der union in der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel haben
wir den allgemeinen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn in deutschland zum ersten
januar 2015 eingeführt wir haben dies in
diesem bewusstsein getan dass gute
arbeit in deutschland auch fair entlohnt
werden muss dort wo der
tarifvertraglichen schutz nicht oder
nicht hinreichend ausgebildet ist
braucht es eine angemessene
lohnuntergrenze um zu verhindern dass
der wettbewerb zwischen unternehmen auf
den rücken von beschäftigten ausgetragen
wird und wir wollen auch damit dafür
sorgen dass man von dem lohn
auch tatsächlich leben kann der
mindestlohn hat sich bewährt durch die
beschlüsse der mindestlohn kommission
liegt die höhe des mindestlohns aktuell
bei 9 eur 82 sie steigt zum ersten juli
dieses jahres noch einmal weiter an auf
10 eur 45 und nun soll der mindestlohn
auf 12 euro erhöht werden dies erfolgt
jetzt nicht auf der grundlage der
beschlüsse der mindestlohn kommission
sondern durch eine politische setzung
des gesetzgebers und ich will an dieser
stelle hier ganz klar sagen ein
mindestlohn von 12 euro ist angemessen
und erst richtig 12 euro sind
eine wichtige
unterstützung von menschen mit geringen
einkommen
6 millionen arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer
profitieren davon der minister hat
darauf hingewiesen es sind überwiegend
frauen und sie sind es ja die infolge
von mehrfachbelastungen familie und
beruf in einklang zu bringen häufiger im
niedriglohnbereich beschäftigt sind und
deshalb auch niedriger renten haben
und zugleich bleibt aber auch der
hinweis wichtig dass wir in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft wieder unsrigen
keine politische lohnfindung wollen das
lehnen wir ab ein überbietungswettbewerb
in der höhe von löhnen meistens
vorgetragen ja dann zu wahlkampfzeiten
ist
brandgefährlich ein solcher wettbewerb
schwächt die sozialpartnerschaft wir
brauchen jedoch starke arbeitgeber
starke gewerkschaften und wir dürfen sie
nicht beschädigen und letztendlich würde
ein solcher überbietungswettbewerb wenn
er auf dauer ausgetragen würde zu lasten
der schwächsten am arbeitsmarkt gehen
denn sie sind es die letztendlich durch
neue einzels barrieren in den
arbeitsmarkt gehindert werden wir
brauchen jedoch nicht neue hürden
sondern weniger und wir wollen auch dass
der erhöhte mindestlohn von 12 euro
tatsächlich bei den menschen ankommt und
zwar dauerhaft
eine vollzeitbeschäftigte arbeitskraft
mit 40 stunden beispielsweise für sie
bedeutet die erhöhung ein einkommensplus
von brutto 270 euro er verdient rund 15
prozent mehr gegenüber einer mindestlohn
in höhe von zehn euro 45 er muss aber 48
prozent mehr steuern zahlen im
verhältnis also muss er mehr steuern
zahlen als vorher und ursache dafür ist
die gestaltung des steuertarifs wir
nennen das auch kalte progression und
die kalte progression ist es die wir
verhindern müssen in diesem bereich
damit diese erhöhung des mindestlohns
tatsächlich auch bei den menschen
ankommt von 12 und die kalt und klar in
händen des bundesfinanzminister dürfen
nicht tief in die taschen der
geringverdiener sich hinein graben und
hier ist die bundesregierung gefordert
tatsächlich aktiv zu werden den effekt
den effekt der kaltenbrunn effekt den
effekt der kalten progression und das
bleiben sie tatsächlich schuldig wir
brauchen mehr netto vom brutto und hier
liefert die bundesregierung an dieser
stelle nicht und das ist etwas was wir
gelangen und auch klammer und ein
zweiter effekt der hinzu kommt
der ist der steigenden sozialbeiträgen
die entwicklung der abgabenlast kennt
absehbar bei dieser koalition nur eine
entwicklung und zwar die nach oben bei
der krankenversicherung ist für rund 17
milliarden euro für 20 23 bei der
pflegeversicherung auch da ein defizit
bei der rente und bei der
arbeitslosenversicherung
sind ja bereits erhöhungen entsprechend
angekündigt es droht in diesem auf der
ganzen breite 1 beitragssatz zunahme und
auch hier ist die bundesregierung
gefordert die bei die sozialbeiträge
stabil zu halten denn sie sind es
letztendlich die es in besonderem maße
geringverdiener belasten wir haben das
gemacht als union mit unserer sozial
garantie von 40 prozent diese koalition
bleibt diesen ansatz schuldig
und ein dritter effekt kommt hinzu
es ist der massive kaufkraftverluste den
wir derzeit erfahren von 7 prozent in
diesem in diesem monat das merken wir
bei den grundnahrungsmitteln bei den
spritpreisen bei den heizkosten auch das
belastet natürlich
bezieherinnen und bezieher gerade von
geringen einkommen in massiver art und
weise und auch da muss diese koalition
mehr tun als sie es tatsächlich nach
doch auch hier ist wieder der ansatz der
steuer hier können sie zeigen dass sie
tatsächlich dafür sorge tragen dass die
erhöhung von zwei auf zwölf euro
mindestlohn tatsächlich auch bei den
menschen ankommt und die mindest
lohnerhöhung davon sollen ja auch
diejenigen profitieren die in einem
minijob beschäftigt sind das ist richtig
dass dies getan wird nötig ist als auch
und richtig dass diese dynamisiert wird
und sie gehen auch eine teilzeit falle
an nämlich den übergang zwischen minijob
und midijob aber das was sie tun ist
nicht die lösung auch da müssen sie an
das steuerrecht hin amtieren um die
teilzeit falle tatsächlich wirksam zur
detail zu beseitigen es bleibt viel zu
tun für diese koalition um es richtig zu
machen
stirn stracke für die cdu/csu hat gesagt
ein mindestlohn von 12 euro ist
angemessen und richtig wir wollen
allerdings keine politische vor lohn
finden und es bleibe das problem dass
durch diesen mindestlohn nicht genug
geld im portemonnaie der arbeitnehmer
bleibt gericht den kalte progression der
steuertarif er müsse verändert werden
frank zilles gespräche für arbeit und
soziales der bündnisgrünen vor 2015 eine
gesetzliche lohnuntergrenze eingezogen
wurde
befanden sich die löhne in vielen
bereichen auf einer rutschbahn nach
unten begünstigt durch eine sinkende
tarifbindung
mitgliedschaften arbeitgeberverbänden
ohne tarifbindung und das ausscheren
viele unternehmen aus tarifverträgen
führten dazu dass immer mehr menschen
statt von tarifverträgen geschützt zu
sein sich konfrontiert sagen mit der
rückkehr von unsicherheit damit das
eigene leben im zweiten prekäre
arbeitsverhältnisse nicht mehr wirklich
planen zu können damit von armut bedroht
zu sein obwohl sie arbeiteten arbeitende
armut eben
die alten des gesetzlichen mindestlohns
war ein wichtiger schritt dem
entgegenzutreten es war eine reaktion
auf die anhaltende rückläufige gericht
bindung und entsprach dem willen der
großen mehrheit der menschen in unserem
land die nämlich nicht in einer
gesellschaft leben wollen in der arbeit
macht und entwürdigt
mit dem mindestlohn
mit dem mindestmaß klargestellt worden
dass es rote linien gibt die zu
überschreiten politisch nicht zugelassen
werden sollen genauso wie es seinerzeit
auch ein us präsident
franklin delano roosevelt auf den punkt
gebracht hat als er bei einführung des
nationalen gesetzlichen mindestlohn
sagte zitat
unternehmen die ihren beschäftigten
weniger als ein zum lebenden
ausreichenden lohn zahlen sollen in
diesem land kein recht mehr haben weiter
ihre geschäfte zu betreiben zitat ende
wenn wir nun holte
wenn man heute sieben jahre nach
einführung des gesetzlichen mindestlohns
in deutschland schauen wo wir stehen
so müssen wir feststellen
deutschland befindet sich im
langfristigen eu vergleich weit
abgeschlagen auf einem der letzten
plätze der
mindestlohns seit seiner einführung nur
um 15 5 prozent gestiegen da bleibt nach
abzug der inflation nur eine reale
steigerung von weniger als einem prozent
pro jahr dem wollen wir nicht länger
zuschauen
mit der anhebung auf 12 euro
bringen wir den deutschen mindestlohn in
die nähe des auch von der eu-kommission
für notwendig gehalten dem richtplatz
von 60% des medialen lohns jenseits der
armutsgefährdung und verbessern so die
entlohnung von rund sechs millionen
menschen in unserem land das hilft
vielen ja jetzt angesichts steigender
preise die die menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen ja besonders hart treffen von
der anhebung profitieren insbesondere
menschen in den neuen bundesländern und
vor allem auch frauen haben die doch ein
doppelt so hohes risiko wie männer zu
löhnen unterhalb von 12 euro zu arbeiten
es nun durchaus bemerkenswert die darauf
jetzt reagiert wird
dieselben dieselben arbeitgeberverbands
funktionäre die sich öffentlich die in
der mindestlohn kommission stets gegen
deutliche anhebung des mindestlohns
gesträubt haben erklären nun
das problem sei erreicht die höhe von 12
euro die sei durchaus vertretbar das
problem sei dass der schritt politisch
beschlossen werden soll das sind
dieselben leute die seit vielen jahren
die augen davor verschließen dass ich
der ich bin noch kontinuierlich sinkt
von rund 85 prozent anfang der 90er
jahre auf knapp 50 prozent heute das
sind dieselben leute die ot
mitgliedschaft den arbeitgeber wenden
kultivieren und bestens damit klarkommen
dass tarif unterbietung zugstrecke
zusätzliche profite und höherer
dividenden längst auch in der beletage
deutsche unternehmen angekommen ist wie
zb in der hoch profitablen
wohnungswirtschaft
so weiteren die regulierung braucht bei
einer solchen braucht man bei anderen
solchen ausgangslage keine neuen gesetze
mehr staatliches nichtstun reicht
vollkommen aus dann können sich die
tarifautonomie in teilen der wirtschaft
von selbst erledigen wenn nicht
gegengesteuert wird dazu aber gegen zu
steuern sind wir fest entschlossen
ein höherer mindestlohn ist notwendig
reicht aber nicht aus denn das
wirkungsvolle ins wirkungsvollste
instrument und die ungleichheit der
markteinkommen zu verringern das ist und
bleibt eine höhere und eine hohe
tarifbindung
dazu werden hier
ein bundesgesetz erlassen und die
kollektive nachdrucken von
tarifverträgen im unternehmensverbund
fest schreiben und werden weitere
schritte prüfen
denn ohne die stärken des
betriebssystems ohne die festigung der
bindungskraft von tarifverträgen wird
sich die ungleichheit in der
einkommensverteilung weiter verfestigen
oder sogar noch erhöhen
ist es nun
mit risiken verbunden den mindestlohn in
einem schritt auf 12 euro anzuheben
schritte wie dieser haben nirgendwo zu
relevanten negativen konsequenzen für
den arbeitsmarkt geführt in
großbritannien zum beispiel ist ein
mindestlohn bereits auf 60 prozent
angehoben des median und soll bis 2024
weiter auf 66 prozent erhöht werden die
erhebung auf 12 euro ist deshalb auch
ein signal in richtung mindestlohn
kommission
den mindestlohn mutig weiter zu
entwickeln dafür zu sorgen dass er nicht
wieder unter 60 prozent des medians
fällt dafür zu sorgen dass der
mindestlohn für eine auskömmliche rente
reicht da sind wir nicht auch nicht mit
zwölf euro aber da sollten wir hin dass
dies erreicht wird dass es gelingt da
ich bin doch wieder zu erhöhen das ist
zentral um faire entlohnungsbedingungen
für alle menschen in unserem land zu
ermöglichen in einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft in der arbeit nicht
macht und nicht entwürdigt
hier werden die bezirke
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist nun endlich irgendwo
fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine
damen und herren es ist die erste
aufgabe und pflicht der opposition nötig
wasser denn da hin zu gießen und die
wahrheit auszusprechen
der vorliegende entwurf des mindestlohn
erhöhung des gesetzes ist zuvor ost ein
wahlgeschenk ein wahlversprechen das
auch in einer gänzlich andere zeit
abgegeben wurde heute leben wir
seit der wiedervereinigung in der
höchsten inflationsrate von bald zehn
prozent diese inflation raub
normalverdiener und rentnern im land die
mühsam erarbeitete
existenzgrundlage darum handeln wir
mindestlohngesetz vorbei warum takt
trotz grassierender inflation die
mindestlohn-kommission nicht im juni
2020 war die letzte tagung seit dieser
zeit wird die teuerung konsequent
ignoriert weil der damen und herren ja
bisher stärkste mindestlohn stieg und
satte 22 prozent wird in zeiten rasant
kritischer inflation alsbald von der
teuerung aufgefressen zwar ist die
betrachtung der erhöhung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohnes auf zwölf
euro pro arbeitsstunde grundsätzlich zu
begrüßen doch wir wissen seit einer
anfrage der nunmehr zu verleihen und
linksfraktion aus dem jahr 2018 das rein
rechnerisch ein mindestlohn für 12 eur
63 nötig ist aber der altersrente
oberhalb der grundsicherung zu
gewährleisten demnach garantiert hier in
rede stehende mindestlohn erhöhung nicht
einmal einen schutz vor altersarmut das
scharf zu kritisieren ist
zurück
somit fällt das wahlgeschenk für holen 6
millionen beschäftigte dann doch nicht
so generös aus wir uns die
ampelkoalition ehre und die
parteizentrale weismachen wollen und
eigentlich schlimmer meine damen und
herren wie das die wie zutreffend fest
stellt die von armut betroffenen
haushalte sind nicht die die für
mindestlohn profitieren
dies weil der effekt des bündnis lohnes
als instrument zur bekämpfung von
familienabend sehr begrenztes die
gegenwärtige inflation trifft die arm
ungleich härter ist die reichen
bevölkerungsgruppen so weiß
armutsforscher ob das futter rege ich
zitiere wer mehr als 5000 euro im netto
im monat verdient den bringt es nicht um
wenn seine lebenshaltungskosten 4,8
prozent steigen
ein paket wurde in münchen mit 1300 euro
netto macht denn die um 8 4% höheren
preise aber noch erbe das wort zum
zeitpunkt 4,8 prozent zur erinnerung wir
stehen jetzt bei 7,3 prozent inflation
empirische analysen dass die wii zeigen
was der anstieg des mindestlohnes für
viele beschäftigte vor allen dingen den
minijobs oder in teilzeit mit einem
rückgang der arbeitsstunden einhergeht
daher über setzt sich das wachstum des
stundenlohnes nicht unmittelbar in ein
wachstum des monatseinkommens und alle
sozialpolitiker dieses hauses wissen das
kurzum die bluse die bloße erhöhung des
mindestlohnes löst nicht die probleme
des deutschen arbeitnehmer diese
diese probleme
ligen tiefer und sind grundsätzlicher
natur der gesetzliche mindestlohn ist
doch nur ausdruck der krise des
sozialstaates sowie eines völlig maroden
lohn geflügels dass wir heute mit den
mindestlöhnen system kosmetik betreiben
hat eigentlich seine ursache mit
unsäglichen lohnzurückhaltung der
letzten jahre
unsere unsoziale sozialdemokraten unter
den nunmehr nicht geliebten kanzler
schröder und die abgehobenen grünen den
gestaltern von
denen haben wir dieses elend zu
verdanken die politisch gewollte
lohnzurückhaltung also das nicht
ausschöpfen des verteilungsspielraum
tauss produktivitätszuwächse kostete
nicht nur lohn zurück auf
hunderttausende von arbeitsplätzen das
ein verschenkter wachstums und
wohlstands chancen in deutschland dann
braucht man nämlich einen mindestlohn
wenn man solche schadens und verschenken
die auf das konto von rot-grün gene
brutale die regulierung des
arbeitsmarktes und hartz4 führte wie wir
heute wissen zu einem dramatischen
anstieg von prekären
beschäftigungsverhältnissen und
leiharbeit meistens zu hungerlöhnen zu
einer massiven ausweitung von teilzeit
beziehungsweise
befristeten jobs oder liegt der hase im
pfeffer alle maßnahmen zur lohnerhöhung
werden die durch die neuerliche
ausweitung atypische arbeitsverhältnisse
konterkariert das ist genau der punkt wo
wir so ansetzen will die afg als soziale
volkspartei
machen sie weiter ihre wieder nach oben
das habe ich hier in der letzten
legislatur erklärt die schauen alles wir
wollen auch das tun für die arbeitnehmer
machen sie weiter
das ist genau der punkt wo wir als ard
einsetzen als soziale volkspartei die
sich um die belange der arbeitgeber und
der steuerzahler käme drei dinge sind
für uns und verhandelbar erstens man
muss von seiner arbeit leben können
zweitens man muss von seiner arbeit eine
familie gründen können und drittens
diese familie auch ernähren
ziel der fdp ist mit einer soliden
wirtschaft und sozialpolitik
mindestlöhne endlich überflüssig werden
zu lassen wir brauchen den wohlstand nur
zum wohle der arbeitnehmer und der
familie und zu diesen aspekten stimmen
wir über weise den ausschüssen
dankeschön
soweit hier ein pool von der afg meine
damen und herren der bundeskanzler ist
heute nicht hier ist gestern abend nach
japan aufgebrochen oder auf scholz' die
bundesrepublik deutschland hat den
vorsitz bei der g7 und gemeinsam mit dem
japanischen ministerpräsidenten wird
olaf scholz in den nächsten 20 minuten
eine pressekonferenz geben wir werden
versuchen ihnen die dann hier zu
übertragen 1 wahlen geht es aber weiter
mit pascal kober von der fdp hier im
bundestag
decke auf der minijob grenze wird nun
endlich einmal die minijob jens erhöht
und das ist eine gute nachricht für
6,2 millionen bürgerinnen und bürger in
unserem land die in einem minijob
arbeiten
und zum ersten mal wieder seit 23 jahren
noch die minijob grenze dynamisiert seit
1999 war sie stark festgeschrieben wurde
das letzte mal auf 450 euro bei der
regierungsbeteiligung fdp 2013 erhöht
und damit hören wir jetzt auf wir werden
sie wieder dynamisieren und das wird
dazu führen dass alle die auch die
arbeiten auch wirklich von
lohnerhöhungen mehr geld in der tasche
haben können denn bisher ist es ja so
dass bei einer erhöhung des lohns die
minijobberinnen und mini jobber ihre
arbeitszeit reduzieren müssen um nicht
über die grenze zu kommen das ist
ungerecht wir schaffen wir mehr
gerechtigkeit
also werden wir die minijob grenze
künftig berechnen an einer
wochenarbeitszeit von zehn stunden
bei einer durchschnittlichen wochen zeit
pro monat von hier ein drittel macht das
bei der erhöhung des mini des
mindestlohns im ersten schritt 520 euro
und künftig wird er ist eben mit jeder
mindestlohn erhöhung ansteigen das ist
ganz besonders wichtig für die 850.000
minijobberinnen und minijobber die in
einem mindestlohn arbeitsverhältnis aber
und ich weiß herr bundesminister ich
weiß liebe koalitionspartner das war
nicht ihr allererster wunsch aber das
ist die stärke eben dieser koalition
dass wir eben fortschritt ermöglichen
indem wir kompromisse schließen und da
bin ich dankbar dass das möglich mal das
war uns wichtig und dafür haben wir
gemeinsam am ende gekämpft
minijobs
gerade viele minijobberinnen und manager
wurden von der pandemie ganz besonders
hart getroffen weil ihre
arbeitsverhältnisse von einschränkungen
betroffen waren gerade in der
gastronomie beispielsweise noch für sie
ist es jetzt zumindest mal eine kleine
möglichkeit verlorenes einkommen
nachträglich wieder gut zu machen
darüber freuen wir uns und das ist auch
ein gutes zeichen
aber letzten endes wir profitieren alle
von dem minijobberinnen und minijobbern
die morgendliche zeitung dass sonntags
brötchen beim bäcker der besuch im
biergarten all das wäre ohne mini jobs
kaum möglich wir alle profitieren von
dem mini jobs weil in vielen fällen die
angebote nur deshalb gemacht werden
können weil es die motivation von
menschen gibt in einem minijob speziell
in einem minijob zu arbeiten ohne sie
wäre vieles in unserer gesellschaft
nicht möglich und deshalb ist es auch
ein wichtiger lösung die wir anstreben
es sind 3 5 millionen unternehmen in
deutschland die einen oder mindestens
einen minijobber beschäftigen das sind
schüler die beispielsweise über das
austragen von zeitungen ihr
taschengeld aufbessern das sind
studierende lieber da in der arbeit bei
der eine bäckerei beispielsweise oder
natürlich vor allen dingen gastronomie
uns unsere freizeit ermöglichen und sich
damit für das studium etwas
dazuverdienen
oder denken sie an die vielen
rentnerinnen und rentner die nicht mit
einem schlag aus dem erwerbsleben
aussteigen wollen eine untersuchung des
instituts für arbeitsmarkt und
berufsforschung hat ergeben dass 90
prozent derjenigen die im alter nach
renteneintritt noch arbeiten die es tun
weil sie freude an der arbeit haben weil
sich schrittweise aussteigen wollen weil
sie kollegen haben wollen und weil sie
nur eine sinnvolle tätigkeit nachgehen
wollen zumindest
und auch für sie ist es jetzt möglich
von lohnerhöhungen zu profitieren ja und
es gibt
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
gerade auch im handwerk die einen mini
job ganz bewusst auch als eine
freizeitbeschäftigung
ausüben die motiviert sind das zu tun
weil es da euros gibt netto für brutto
und das ist die wahrscheinliche
motivation deswegen die es ermöglichen
können dass die dringend benötigte
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
handwerk aufgefunden werden können auch
für die ist diese lohnerhöhung in
zukunft eine tolle sache und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dieser schritt
war längst überfällig
jetzt ist er gekommen mit dieser
koalition ich danke allen die daran
mitgewirkt haben und freue mich auf die
weiteren beratungen
ende 20 21 gab es mehr als 6,2 6
millionen minijobber im gewerblichen
bereich das sind 74 prozent mehr als im
vorjahr hatte also auch etwas bewirkt
das falsche sagt die linke in ihrem
antrag ausweitung der minijobs
konterkarieren erhöhung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns und das wird er zu seine
fesche vortragen für die linke
wird jetzt realität der mindestlohn wird
auf 12 eur erhöht es ist eine sehr gute
nachricht für millionen von
beschäftigten und es begrüßen und
unterstützen wir natürlich ausdrücklich
ja er hat natürlich auch kritik zum
beispiel das zoomen menschen ohne
berufsausbildung oder
langzeitarbeitslosen oder menschen mit
behinderungen werkstätten auch weiterhin
der mindestlohn vorenthalten wird aber
die dickste kröte in ihrem
gesetzesentwürfen da haben sie gar
nichts dazu gesagt herr minister die
dickste kröte ist die zwölf euro gibt es
nur bei gleichzeitiger ausweitung von
mini jobs also von jobs von denen man
nicht leben kann und das ist ein ganz
ganz schmutziger deal den sie da in der
bundesregierung gemacht haben meine
damen und herren
und nicht nur wir lehnen das ab wie die
online petition von verdi zeigt und die
positionierung der gewerkschaften
innerhalb des dgs und selbstverständlich
wird es auch auf dem ersten mai ein
thema sein und insbesondere grüne und
spd wissen doch ganz genau das mini jobs
ein paradebeispiel für prekäre
beschäftigung ist nicht umsonst wann sie
grüne und spd vor der bundestagswahl
noch für eine massive eindämmung und
gute gründe dafür gibt es genug
wir sind nicht sozial abgesichert sie
haben weder anspruch auf kurzarbeiter
arbeitslosen oder krankengeld sie werden
kaum rentenansprüche und insbesondere
betroffen davon sind frauen
und das ifo-institut hat erst letzte
woche bestätigt dass sich durch ihr
gesetz die teilzeit falle für frauen
verschärfen wird sich verursachen als
auch noch ein gleichstellungs
politisches desaster ist völlig
inakzeptabel
betroffen sind fast immer beschäftigte
zweiter klasse tarifliche bezahlung
entgeltfortzahlung im krankheitsfall
urlaub usw meistens fehlanzeige und die
aufzählung könnte ich als langjährige
betriebsräten noch eine ganze weile
weiter führen aber was dem ganzen
wirklich die krone aufsetzt ist dass sie
durch diese regelung die erhöhung des
mindestlohns konterkarieren denn mini
jobs ohne stimmt schon minijobs ohne
tagesaktueller und ohne
manipulationssichere arbeits
aufzeichnung ist das haupteinfallstor
für mindestlohn betrug und aktuell
werden schon zweieinhalb millionen
beschäftigte um ihren lohn betrogen das
ist doch wahnsinn
und sie zeigen einen kontrollen zu
mindestlohn auch nicht alle register
auch hier sehen wir großen nachholbedarf
die regelungen zur arbeitszeit
aufzeichnung beispielsweise die stand im
referentenentwurf noch drin und wurde
ganz offensichtlich auf wunsch der fdp
gestrichen man könnte fast meinen dass
dieser lohn auch an den beschäftigten
nicht nur billigend sondern vorsätzlich
in kauf genommen wird und das ist teil
des schmutzigen deals und das ist meine
damen und herren war
und schädigte sei an der stelle auch
erwähnt ist auch das verhalten der
arbeitgeber die die ganze zeit den
fachkräftemangel jammern und jetzt
juristisch gegen die mindestlohn
anhörung vorgehen wollen sie als
bundesregierung könnten dem eine abhilfe
schaffen weiten sie prekäre
beschäftigung nicht aus sondern denen
sie sie ein das hilft nämlich gegen den
fachkräftemangel
setzen sie beschäftigt auch die sozialen
sicherungssysteme jede stunde arbeit
muss sozialversicherungspflichtig sein
und das will laut einer umfrage des dgb
auch die mehrheit der befragten noch
haben sie die chance diese kröte aus
diesem gesetzesentwurf wieder raus zu
streichen sie haben uns bei der erhöhung
des mindestlohns voll und ganz an ihrer
seite aber die ausweitung von millions
mit minijobs lehnen wir strikt ab vielen
dank
so wird also susanne fesche mit der
position der linksfraktion die
bundesregierung will ich in ihrem
gesetzentwurf die grenze für minijobs
von 450 auf 520 euro anheben und einen
mindestlohn von 12 euro ein verlust
für die union
ein bernd rützel ist das ballon für die
spd unsere aufgaben die wir uns vor dem
24 februar vorgenommen haben weiterhin
beackern äußere sicherheit innere
sicherheit ist genauso wichtig wie
soziale sicherheit und deswegen erhöhen
will mindestlohn zum ersten oktober auf
12 euro liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
6,2 millionen menschen profitieren davon
und wir begegnen ihnen täglich wir
kennen sie das ist die verkäuferin in
der bäckerei es ist der reiniger der die
büros und die bahnen und die busse
saubermacht hubertus heil und minister
ganz viele beispiele genannt die
frisörin die uns die pakete liefern und
so weiter all das sind die menschen
denen wir respekt zollen müssen denen
wir dankbar sein müssen dass unser leben
so wie wir es kennen läuft die frühes
aufstehen die abends noch tätig sind in
der nachtschicht sind die hart arbeiten
und wer vollzeit arbeitet muss von
seinem lohn leben können das ist ein
wichtiger vorsatz
amerikanischen präsidenten sondern auch
noch von päpsten
der mindestlohn ist aber kein normal
lohn er ist eine lohnuntergrenze alles
was darunter ist ist sittenwidrig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und lieber
kollege stephan stracke er hat mich
nicht stephan stracke man erste rede im
deutschen bundestag hatte ich zum
mindestlohn gehalten und seitdem haben
wir uns viel auseinandergesetzt
und beschäftigt ich kann mich an vieles
erinnern
ich kann mich auch daran erinnern dass
2014 noch die csu in ganz bayern
plakatiert hat gegen den mindestlohn es
hat nichts genutzt ich bin sehr froh
dass heute das ganze aus glücklich ist
über die erfolgsgeschichte des
mindestlohnes und auch nicht mehr über
die höhe des mindestlohnes diskutieren
ja wenn es 400 euro mehr gibt am ende
cache in trash dann muss man natürlich
auch mehr steuern bezahlen und dann
kommen auch 700 millionen euro mehr in
die sozialkassen hinein die wieder unser
system stützen und deswegen ist der
mindestlohn insgesamt absolut notwendig
und an der erfolgsmodelle
aber der mindestlohn ist ein
mindeststandards er ist kein gold
standard der goldstandard
sind tarifverträge und der goldstandard
ist
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung das ist das was man
anstreben soll
auch mit dem neuen mindestlohn lassen
sich keine großen sprünge machen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen aber es geht um
respekt und es geht auch hauptsächlich
darum dass viele frauen in diesen
berufen beschäftigt sind es ist nämlich
eine frage der gleichberechtigung dass
man die erhöhung des mindestlohns auch
gerade bei frauen durchsetzte in
dienstleistungsberufen sind das ist
dringend notwendig und noch ein satz
auch die volkswirtschaft wird
produktiver die kaufkraft steigt durch
den mindestlohn weil die leute die gäste
12 euro bekommen die nicht auf die
cayman islands bringen sondern im
nächsten geschäft auf ausgeben und
deswegen ist es wichtig
mit einem höheren mindestlohn von ganz
12 euro
profitieren auch tariflöhne weil es
tariflöhne gibt die kurz darüber oder
sogar auch noch unter den zwölf euro
liegen und dicklichen auch noch
romantisch und lieber frank des gewähren
uns diese woche unterhalten es sind sehr
viele menschen die auch noch einmal dann
von höheren tariflöhnen profitieren und
das ist doch ganz positives zeichen
über tariflöhne spricht ihn vorher
nachher über minijobs die eine close und
liebe jasmin fach chemie
wir müssen dich gehen lassen du erhältst
vielleicht heute deine letzte rede hier
und wenn die delegierten des dgb
kongresses dich wählen dann freuen wir
uns dass du unser nächster dgb chefin
wisst
ich wünsche uns allen
[Applaus]
überall hinaustragen einen schönen
ersten mal
danke sie bernd rützel der hier noch mal
hat sie toll der mindestlohn ist und
dass man natürlich dadurch ein höheres
steueraufkommen als man das
finanzminister hat selbstverständlich
vielleicht kann wilfried eggers die
kritik der union noch mal herzl näher
bringen nämlich die tatsache dass kaum
was von der erhöhung übrig bleibt durch
den progressiven anstieg bei den
steuertarifen
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wie hoch
soll der gesetzlichen mindestlohn sein
wer soll ihn bestimmen und wie viel soll
man im rahmen eines mini jobs auch
nebenher verdienen können auf diese und
weitere fragen geht das durch die
bundesregierung eingebrachte gesetz zur
erhöhung des gesetzlichen mindestlohns
ein auch wenn der krieg in der ukraine
das bestimmende thema dieser tage ist so
sind auch diese fragen wichtige fragen
der aktuellen politik in der derzeitigen
situation die von preissteigerungen
geprägt ist ist ein lohn von mindestens
12 euro nicht infrage zu stellen
schließlich gebern arbeiten um auch
davon leben das leben zu bezahlen und im
alter eine auskömmliche rente zu haben
so einverstanden wir mit den zwölf euro
sind so umfangreicher muss man
allerdings die frage diskutieren wer
eigentlich den mindestlohn bestimmen
soll bei der einführung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns war sich die damalige große
koalition einig darüber dass es ein
einmaliger eingriff in die ureigenste
aufgabe der tarifpartner sein sollte die
lohnfindung zu gestalten selbst andrea
nahles hat dies auch damals ganz
deutlich als arbeitsministerin gesagt
die große koalition war sich auch einig
darüber dass ab inkrafttreten des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns die
weiterentwicklung letztlich in die
mindestlohn-kommission und damit in die
hände der tarifpartner gelegt werden
soll weil nämlich gerade die
tarifpartnerschaft auch in allen reden
hoch gehalten wird und in der
mindestlohn kommission im ergebnis auch
praktiziert und gelebt wird daher sollte
die weiterentwicklung des mindestlohns
auch dort verortet sein und nicht hier
im parlament
die einhaltung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns muss allerdings auch
entsprechend kontrolliert seien
kontrolliert werden und auch
kontrollierbar sein und damit komme ich
zum thema der dokumentation
es ist erforderlich dass dokumentiert
wird damit kontrolliert werden kann
allerdings jetzt den schwellenwert
anzuheben von etwa 2900 euro auf über
4100 euro scheint doch sehr überzogen zu
sein zumal wenn man die berechnungen in
der begründung des gesetzgebungs
textes liest dass man von 348
arbeitsstunden monatlich ausgeht bei 29
arbeitstagen so scheint dies doch an der
realität vorbei zu gehen es wäre
richtiger hier nicht auf bestimmte
beträge nicht auf bestimmte gesamt löhne
zu setzen sondern eher auf den
eigentlichen stundenlohn und hier sehen
wir nachbesserungsbedarf
aber man muss auch die frage stellen
welche wege sonst noch gibt damit die
leute mehr geld in der tasche haben weil
das ist ja schließlich auch die frage
die ja mit der erhöhung des mindestlohns
beantwortet werden soll und mehr geld in
der tasche das ist auf der einen seite
natürlich eine möglichkeit zu sagen wir
greifen hier in die aufgabe
mindestlohn-kommission auf der anderen
seite kann der staat aber auch seinen
beitrag dazu leisten indem er abgaben
und steuern entsprechend senkt wir haben
zu einer letzten legislaturperiode so
gemacht dass mit der abschaffung des
soli für viele menschen mehr geld in der
tasche da war unter stichwort karte
progression hat mein kollege strecke
eben schon angesprochen
finanziell finanzielle mittel gibt es
dazu weil durch die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auch mehr steuereinnahmen
generiert werden und auch soziale minder
aus oder minderausgaben in den
sozialkassen auch entsprechend zu
verzeichnen sind daher wird das geld
schon da sein gestatten sie mir eine
letzte anmerkung zu den inklusions
unternehmen weil wir sollten auch hier
sehen das dem ja dass die erhöhung des
mindestlohns weitere auswirkungen hat
inklusions unternehmen bekommen einen
nachteilsausgleich die bescheide sind
schon geschrieben gehen über den ersten
zehn
2022 hinaus und deswegen muss auch hier
im parlamentarischen verfahren meinen
augen eine lösung gefunden werden ich
freue mich auch die beratung im
bundestag debattiert über den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn wäre und
geringfügig geschäft geringfügige
beschäftigung ein antrag der
regierungsfraktionen
wir gucken auch immer mit einem auge
nach tod wird in der bundeskanzler ist
gestern nach tokio geflogen und wird
dort gleich eine pressekonferenz geben
wir werden versuchen ihnen die sich hier
zu präsentieren
zunächst aber geht es weiter mit beate
müller gemmeke von den ministerien
opposition und jetzt können wir endlich
politisch gestalten das ist aber gar
nicht so einfach denn in so einer art
haben wir natürlich bei manchen themen
nicht immer aber bei manchen themen
unterschiedliche einschätzungen und
unterschiedliche ziele und dann wundert
es auch nicht dass wir das gesetz heute
auch unterschiedlich bewerten wenn es um
die veränderungen bei den minijobs geht
dann sind wir grüne nur an einer stelle
wirklich zufrieden einen höheren
mindestlohn hingegen fordern wir schon
lange denn jegliche arbeit hat ihren
wert und muss deshalb fair entlohnt
werden
euro mindestlohn das bringt über sechs
millionen beschäftigten ganz konkrete
verbesserungen 3,5 millionen frauen
werden mehr im geldbeutel haben das sind
immerhin 20 prozent der weiblichen
beschäftigten im bereich gastronomie und
hotels werden zwei drittel der
beschäftigten von einem höheren
mindestlohn profitieren und profitieren
werden auch all diejenigen die in den
krankenhäusern dass das essen ausgeben
oder die zimmer reinigen das ist arbeit
die wir in zeiten von corona als
systemrelevant bezeichnen die aber
scheinbar nichts kosten darf diese
zahlen machen deutlich wie hoch der
niedriglohnsektor in deutschland ist es
wäre falsch das weiterhin zu ignorieren
wir müssen hier politisch eingreifen und
in mindestlohn endlich auf 12 euro
erhöhen
david wir den mindestlohn erhöhen können
mussten wir aber bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen eine bittere
pille schlucken
und das war die erhöhung dafür minijob
verdienstgrenze auf 520 euro und
kollegin ferschl das ist eben die harte
regierungsarbeit diese regelungen da bin
ich ganz offen und ehrlich tut richtig
richtig weh denn wir vertreten natürlich
noch immer die auffassung dass die mend
minijobs enorme nachteile haben und dass
das deshalb auch kleine jobs unbedingt
sozialversicherungspflichtig seien
wüssten davon würden die
sozialversicherungen profitieren und vor
allem auch die beschäftigten und hier
insbesondere die frauen
und deshalb ist es uns besonders wichtig
dass mini jobs für frauen keine teilzeit
vater sein dürfen minijobs dürfen auch
nicht als ersatz für reguläre
arbeitsverhältnisse missbraucht werden
und beides haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben und dort steht auch dass
wir die hürden abbauen wollen die einen
wechsel im versicherungs
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung erschweren und genau das
tun wir auch wir erleichtern den
übergang vom mini job in midi job und
diese regelung ist wirklich richtig gut
diese verbesserung ist wichtig denn
viele frauen wollen aus dem mini job
raus und länger arbeiten wir heute aber
der minijob bereich verlässt und nur
wenig mehr verdient muss sofort 52 euro
in die sozialversicherung zahlen die
frauen verdienen also teilweise erst
einmal weniger obwohl sie mehr arbeiten
und genau diese stelle haben wir
geglättet künftig fallen beim wechsel in
die sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung erst mal gar keine
sozialabgaben an 52 euro dann erst bei
einem verdienst von 700 euro die
belastung steigt dann ganz lang da man
bis zu einem verdienst von 1600 euro
damit schaffen wir also diese hürde beim
übergang in reguläre beschäftigung ab
das ist gut und das ist wichtig und das
war uns ein besonderes anliegen
ja und wenn wir dann noch ein antrags
vorhaben der ampel umsetzen und endlich
die leidige steuerklasse 5 abschaffen
wenn frauen dann eben nicht mehr ständig
das gefühl haben dass sie zwar arbeiten
aber das dass es sich eigentlich gar
nicht lohnt zu arbeiten weil fast nichts
übrig bleibt dann wird der wechsel in
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit
noch attraktiver
mehr sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung ja das ist unser ziel ob
uns das mit diesem gesetz gelingt ob
mini jobs nicht mehr zur teilzeit falle
wird all das werden wir am ende mit
einer studie auch noch überprüfen ich
hoffe auf ein positives ergebnis und
wenn das ergebnis nicht gut ist dann
müssen wir nachsteuern aber unabhängig
davon das gesetz heute ist wichtig denn
zwölf euro mindestlohn das ist einfach
eine frage der gerechtigkeit vielen dank
ja und wichtig ist auch dass ich meine
aussage von eben noch mal korrigieren
nicht die fraktionen bringen dieses
gesetz ein in erster lesung sondern
natürlich die bundesregierung
gesetzlicher mindestlohn auf 12 euro
sowie im bereich geringfügiger
beschäftigung eine aussetzung von 450
auf 520 euro erster lesung so ist es
richtig und karl julius kronberg jetzt
für die fdp hat jetzt nächster redner
das wort liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es dürfte
das soho house nur bedingt überraschend
wenn ich feststelle dass die idee den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn
auf 12 euro anzuheben nicht im
wahlprogramm der freien demokraten
entsprungen ist
aber offensichtlich haben unsere partner
von der sozialdemokratie bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen so bestechen
durch argumente vorgetragen dass wir
schon ein gesetzentwurf einbringen
könnte
noch schneller noch schneller als wir
war die kritik der union
die kam schon im januar der geschätzte
kollege richard dabei in seiner
argumentation ausgiebig auf einen fdp
antrag aus dem letzten jahr
gestützt was die bedeutung der
unabhängigkeit der mindestlohn
kommission betont also wenn die
anpassung des mindestlohns als erstes
dazu führt dass die union ihren
ordnungspolitischen kompass an den
anträgen der fdp ausrichtet ja dann ist
das erst einmal eine gute nachricht die
runde gemacht
dennoch hörte kollegen von der union
empfehle ich einen blick ins gesetz war
auf 1 absatz 2 besagt dass die anpassung
des mindestlohns durch rechtsverordnung
der bundesregierung auf vorschlag der
mindestlohn kommission erfolgt würde die
regierung bei der 12 euro erhöhung die
mindestlohn-kommission einspannen die
von ihnen im januar gefordert würde sie
diese quasi nötigen 12 euro zu empfehlen
dann hätten wir genau die einschränkung
ihrer unabhängigkeit die wir vermeiden
wollen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb hat die koalition
bewusstsein an und die welt und die
kommission ein dass im spiel genommen um
ihre unabhängigkeit abzustützen
wir alle wissen dass viele betriebe oft
kleine gleich die die unterkochener
gelitten haben und
personalkostenanteil haben durch die 15
prozent erhöhung belastet werden
koalition weiß das und nimmt die sorgen
der arzt aus diesem grund entlasten wir
kleine und mittlere unternehmen an
anderer stelle vorgezogene streichung
der eeg-umlage hilft genau wie
bürokratie entlastungen die kommen
werden und die sicherung der mini jobs
ist darauf eingegangen worden und
kollege stracke wir haben auch den
grundfreibetrag den steuerlichen
grundfreibetrag kräftig angehoben um
eben die folgen für die die jetzt mehr
verdienen zu viel agiert
die annehme und des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns mag man richtig oder falsch
finden aber eins ist klar niemand kann
sich wünschen dass menschen die fleißig
arbeiten am monatsende nur mit
mindestlohn nach hause gehen nun wird
rein statistisch gesehen die kräftige
erhöhung des mindestlohns
voraussichtlich erst einmal dazu führen
dass der anteil an mindestlohn
empfängern an allen beschäftigten
vorübergehend steigt lassen sie jetzt
mich klar sagen unser gemeinsames ziel
muss es sein mit kluger politik dafür zu
sorgen dass diese quote wieder sinkt
dass so viele menschen wie möglich die
chance bekommen am arbeitsmarkt bessere
jobs zu finden als mindestlohn jobs
deshalb machen wir investitionsanreize
für unternehmen in der punk formation
deshalb investitionen schaffen neue
meistens gut bezahlte jobs sowie tesla
die grünen heide nord volt in schleswig
holstein oder intel in magdeburg und
deshalb fördern wir beschäftigte die
sich weiterbilden wollen qualifizierung
sicherheit nicht nur jobs sondern
schafft eben auch aufstiegsmöglichkeiten
einsatz zum antrag der linken der
ausnahmen vom mindestlohn für
auszubildende abschafft der riskiert
ausbildungsplätze der ausnahmen für
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit abschafft der
erschwert ihnen den weg zurück in den
arbeitsmarkt
statt zu helfen beides finde ich nicht
sozial da machen wir nicht mit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen freuen wir uns
mit den menschen die in zukunft nach der
verabschiedung des gesetzes mehr geld
verdienen werden bis dahin freue ich
mich auf die weiteren beratungen
julius kronberg der sprecher für
mittelstand und freihandel für die fdp
bundestagsfraktion
und der vorsitzende der
arbeitnehmergruppe bei der cdu/csu axel
knoerig hat jetzt als nächster das wort
hier im plenum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sie kennen alle
aus ihren wahlkreisen diese berichte von
art arbeitenden mitbürgern den am
monatsende zu wenig übrig bleibt letzte
woche sprach ich mit einer verkäuferin
in meinem wahlkreis sie berichtete mir
dass sie kaum mit ihrem geld auskommt
obwohl sie 40 stunden in der woche
arbeitet am ende stehen dir knapp 1300
euro auf dem konto
damit kam sie bislang einigermaßen über
die runden aber jetzt machen ihr die
steigenden preise schweren zu schaffen
diese situation zu viele menschen in
unserem land sie machen sich große
sorgen wie sie im alltag zurechtkommen
sollen das wurde mir in vielen
gesprächen mit unternehmern
betriebsräten und beschäftigten in den
letzten wochen auch noch einmal
bestätigt herr bundesminister weil sie
es schaffen keine
langfristigen lösungen dafür dass die
menschen mehr im geldbeutel bleibt
stattdessen leiten sie einen politischen
überbietungswettbewerb ein heute 12
morgen 13 wie ist ihr plan
sie schwächen die sozialpartnerschaft 7
die mindestlohn-kommission aus aber kein
konzept dafür wie die arbeit der
kommission verbessert werden kann
es muss zu einer schnelleren umsetzung
der tarifentwicklung kommen hier müssen
sie nach besser machen sie uns mal
konstruktive hilfreiche vorschläge die
einführung die einführung des
mindestlohns von 12 euro ist aus unserer
sicht ein richtiges ziel jeder der hart
arbeitet muss von seinem lohn auch leben
können und nicht auf staatliche
unterstützung angewiesen sein und ich
ergänzen jeder der von dieser erhöhung
profitiert hat sie auch verdient
doch wie viel bleibt davon übrig wenn
die inflation weiter steigt unser
fraktionsvorsitzender fordert völlig zu
recht dass steuerentlastungen kommen
müssen aber diese müssen natürlich auch
richtig gemacht werden ihr
entlastungspaket wirkt nicht zielgerecht
ob millionär oder azubi jeder bekommt
das gleiche für die spd ist die
umverteilung ein hohes gut wo bleibt
denn hier eigentlich die soziale
gerechtigkeit
um denjenigen zu helfen die jetzt am
meisten hilfen brauchen müssen wir das
gegenteil von dem tun was die regierung
macht herr kollege nicht mit der
gießkanne ausschütten sondern gezielt
unterstützen verlangen sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der spd-fraktion nein
und ich frage die fdp
haben sie ihre ideale jetzt muss ich
mich korrigieren schon aufgegeben nein
sie haben ihren kompass fallen lassen
meine damen und herren es ist richtig
minister
bundeskanzler scholz hat die mindestlohn
als wahlkampfschlager würde nutzt der
slogan respekt für dich meine ich der
weg hierher ziemlich fragen sie einmal
die rentner die sie bei der entlastung
der energiekosten ganz bewusst außen vor
gelassen haben ich fasse zusammen zwölf
euro sind das richtige ziel aber zur
wahrheit gehört auch die
mindestlohn-kommission muss strukturell
verbessert werden und jeder einzelne
durch flankierende maßnahmen mehr netto
vom brutto im geldbeutel haben
und dann hat auch die verkäuferinnen in
meinem wahlkreis mehr als 1300 euro auf
dem konto und kann dann ihren
lebensunterhalt auch besser bestreiten
das ist der richtige ansatz danke für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
soweit also axel knoerig
und weniger clusaz wortanteil hat die
spd fraktion eine kurze internation
gebeten die ich zulässig ist keine
persönliche erklärung seine kurzen
dimension
präsident ich möchte noch mal
klarstellen sie haben jetzt gerade von
den verkäuferinnen verkäufern geredet
die mehr lohn bekommen müssen und auch
sollen ich selber bin verkäufer hat mit
fünf euro elf mal angefangen hat 99 und
meine kollegen und kollegen die
verdienen jetzt wenn wir die mindestlohn
beschließen aktuell weniger und für die
ist es wichtig und sie tun so als wenn
wir hier als regierung einen einen beruf
machen für ein gesetz wo die
mindestlohn-kommission in zukunft gar
nicht mehr weiß wie sie weiter arbeiten
sollen ganz im gegenteil ist der fall
der fall ist das ab 30 juni 2023 wieder
getagt wird und der mindestlohn erhöht
wird um einen schritt und der nächste
schritt wird in der legislatur unter
passieren am 30 juni 25 da wird er noch
mal erhöht und das sind auch fakten und
da sollten sie umgesetzt genau nachlesen
denn da steht genau drin
sie haben das die gelegenheit zur
erwiderung
herr kollege sie wissen doch selbst auch
und das war eine kritik die wir
fortlaufend den vergangenen jahren
formuliert haben die nachzeichnung der
tarifverträge und deren ergebnisse sie
wissen selbst dass das bis zu zwei jahre
andauert und das selbst wenn die
mindestlohn-kommission nach zwei jahren
über die nachzeichnung gefunden hat dann
auch noch mal wieder sechs monate ins
land gegangen sind und das bis zu
zweieinhalb jahre im grunde genommen das
ganze angedauert hat das ist ein viel zu
langer zeitraum von daher sagen wir bei
aller kritik auch
noch mal nicht an den zwölf euro müssen
wir doch auch inhaltlich strukturell
verändern und das angebotenen eine
vernünftige steuerentlastung dann bleibt
auch von den zwölf euro mehr übrig
so vielen dank als nächster redner das
wort die kollegin annika klose spd
fraktion
vielen dank sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe zuschauer ich würde mal vermuten
dass die meisten frauen in diesem land
folgende setzt das schon mal gehört
haben uns sehr gut kennen mach dich
nicht abhängig oder pass bloß auf dass
du auf eigenen beinen stehen kannst
zumindest bei mir waren das setzte die
meine mutter und großmutter immer wieder
zu mir gesagt haben als teenager war ich
davon natürlich genervt aber heute ist
mir die bittere realität hinter diesen
sätzen sehr bewusst
nach wie vor bestehen 18% lohnlücke
zwischen männern und frauen das bedeutet
dass frauen oft von ihrer arbeit nicht
leben können teilzeit und prekäre
beschäftigung betreffen ebenfalls vor
allem frauen und entsprechend es ist
auch sind es auch vor allem frauen die
von altersarmut betroffen sind
unser ökonomisches system und vor allem
unser lohngefüge drängt frauen daher
nach wie vor in die ökonomische
abhängigkeit von ihren partner in das
damit gefunden das damit verbundene
macht die stelle und
missbrauchspotenzial muss ich an dieser
stelle wohl kaum weiter ausführen liebe
kolleginnen der weg zu einer echten
gleichstellung von frauen kann nicht
länger sein junge frauen zur vorsicht zu
machen sondern es muss daran liegen dass
wir die rahmenbedingungen schaffen damit
frauen endlich auch ökonomisch auf ihren
eigenen beinen stehen können
maßnahme in diesem gesetz sind dafür ein
sehr wichtiger schritt der mindestlohns
von 12 euro kommt vor allem frauen
zugute da ihre löhne und gehälter im
schnitt niedriger sind der mindestlohn
von 12 euro bringt uns ein ganzes stück
näher zu einer lohnuntergrenze die eine
rente oberhalb der grundsicherung
ermöglicht und somit altersarmut
vorbeugen von diesen mindestlohn von 12
euro profitieren 20 prozent aller
erwerbstätigen frauen in deutschland
eine traurig hohe zahl aber die uns noch
mal sehr eindrücklich zeigt wie wichtig
dieser schritt ist
teil dieses gesetzespakets ist aber auch
die ausweitung der einkommensgrenzen für
mini-jobs auf 520 euro nun ist es kein
geheimnis und das haben wir auch bereits
gehört dass wir sozialdemokratinnen
diese ausweitung nicht unbedingt
gebraucht hätten unter zwei prämissen
dem koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
wurden gehen wir diesen schritt jedoch
mit erstens dürfen minijob keine
reguläre beschäftigung ersetzen zweitens
durch minijobs nicht länger zur teilzeit
falle für frauen werden für uns als
ampelkoalition ist klar dass vor einem
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigungen gestärkt werden muss
und diese mit dieser gesetzesreform
bauen wir daher eine brücke von mini
jobs in die sozialversicherungspflicht
wir schaffen die harte abbruchkanten bei
der überschreitung der minijob grenze ab
eine zwischenfrage aus der fraktion die
linke ihre zeit angehalten und sie haben
bei der beantwortung auch noch
zusätzliche redet
eigentlich kolleginnen dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen ich möchte nur
kurz noch mal nachhaken weil sie gesagt
haben eine prämisse ist das letztendlich
keine regulären jobs ersetzt werden und
ich wollte sie fragen was sie zu der ifo
studie sagen die letzte woche
veröffentlicht worden ist und ich
zitiere den ifo forscher maximilian
böhmer als folge der reform dürften vor
allem männer ihre arbeitszeit erhöhen
werden viele frauen ihre arbeitszeit
verringern und noch häufiger teilzeit
arbeiten werden die teilzeit falle von
der vor allem frauen als zweit
verdienerinnen betroffen sind droht sich
deutlich zu verschärfen was sagen sie
denn zu dieser aussage dann mit ihrer
prämisse
vielen dank frau kollegin für diese
frage ich denke dass eben auch frauen
durch die neue regelung die wir im
übergangsbereich schaffen ehemals als
mini midi jobs bekannt geben doch den
weg finden in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung das ist ja jetzt
wir sind gesetzlich sind dürfte es
vorgesehen dass eben dieser harte
abbruchkanten die ja bisher bestand also
wenn man über die 450 euro dann
künstlich 520 hinaus verdient hat dass
man seine gefühle
sozialversicherungspflicht viel und wann
über 100 euro mehr verdienen musste um
überhaupt am ende mehr netto vom brutto
zu haben dass wir das abschaffen und
deswegen die sozialversicherungsbeiträge
erst geschmeidig ansteigen werden der
arbeitgeberanteil
das will doch brücke war nämlich schon
den deckel job in die
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung deswegen glaube ich dass
dieses instrument was die
bundesregierung vorgeschlagen hat was
wir gerne unterstützen der richtige weg
ist um eben den weg aus der aus dem
minijob herauszufinden das sagen
und das ist auch richtig so dass es
diese brücke gibt denn es ist auch unser
ziel ist insbesondere frauen eben mehr
als zehn stunden die woche arbeiten und
damit eben auch eine eigenständige
ökonomische absicherung erhalten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für eine echte
ökonomische ab gleichstellung von frauen
ist noch viel zu tun insbesondere eine
zügige abschaffung der steuerklasse 5 zu
wünschen trotzdem kann ich voller
überzeugung sagen der tag an dem wir
dieses gesetzespaket beschließen ist ein
guter tag für die frauen in diesem land
[Applaus]
annika klose der tag ist aber heute noch
nicht gekommen denn heute ist die erste
lesen
nächste max straubinger
cdu/csu-fraktion
max straubinger von der csu ist im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
sehr geehrter herr präsident wird die
kolleginnen und kollegen
debattieren der heute die einbringung
zur erhöhung des mit des mini jobs
minijobs und midijobs und gleichzeitig
aber auch die erhöhung des mindestlohns
des gesetzlichen mindestlohn auf zwölf
euro für die ohne ist völlig klar wir
sind die partei einmal der sozialen
stärke für die arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer und für den
wirtschaftlichen standort mit in
deutschland und das ist ja die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir auch
ordentliche löhne zahlen können wir sind
für höhere löhne aber wenn es eine
lohnuntergrenze bedarf so ist es mit
gefordert und wir stimmen natürlich den
zwölf euro zu der kollege stracke und
der anderen kollegen hat es bereits auch
mit getätigt und herr kollege bsirske es
ist mit entscheiden dass auch die
wirtschaftliche grundlage dafür da als
stellen sie sich vor wir hätten zwölf
euro mindestlohn gefordert und
umgesetzten soll umsetzen sollen nach
vor 16 jahren also nach rot grün wo man
fast sechs millionen arbeitslose gehabt
hätten da hätte diese mindestlohn
garantiert wirtschaftlichen schaden
verursacht das muss man auch
verdeutlichen es geht schon auch um das
umfeld also wurde ist mit gemacht worden
ist also wir stehen für die zwölf euro
und wir stehen letztendlich also für
gute löhne für die arbeitnehmer in den
arbeitnehmer aber wir müssen schon im
gesetzgebungsverfahren vielleicht nur
über den einen oder anderen teil auch
mitreden wer schon dargelegt worden die
mindestlohn-kommission hat er bereits
schritte unternommen der mindestlohn ist
zum ersten januar gestiegen und er wird
jetzt zum ersten siebten auch wieder
ansteigen auf 10 eur 45 alles dies ist
mit bürokratie bei den arbeitnehmenden
den arbeitnehmern in den betrieben mit
verbunden und jetzt soll er dann steigen
zum ersten zehn auf zwölf euro ebenfalls
wieder bürokratie bei den betrieben und
darüber hinaus zum ersten januar ja dann
wieder herr kollege also das bedeutet
letztendlich bürokratie ich bin dafür
die bürokratie abzubauen und
dementsprechend ist vielleicht
wesentlich besser darüber nachzudenken
wenn er zum ersten juli der mindestlohn
angepasst wird auch 10.45 macht man doch
die anpassung sofort von zwölf volt zum
ersten sitten ja völlig klar dass eine
oder soll oder sollte erst die zehnte
als hubertus heil gedenktage eingehen in
der lohnpolitik also von daher also ist
das bild eine frage wie man sachlich
auch diskutieren sollte er durch gehört
meines erachtens mit dazu was euch haben
schwarz also an diesem tag oder an
diesem gesetzentwurf ist sind natürlich
auch die vermehrten
aufzeichnungspflichten die angedacht
waren zum teil jetzt zurückgenommen
worden sind aber dass die wenn ich mir
das an mindestlohn orientiere und die
einkommens die monatliche
einkommensgrenze für die stritten
aufzeichnungen sozusagen vor
arbeitsbeginn schon anzumelden ich
arbeite jetzt also und dies zu erreichen
bei
4176 euro zugrunde gelegt wird dass er
bedeutet wenn die zwölf euro in der
stunde bekomme dann
348 monat stunden bedeuten würde also
kann man nicht vorstellen dass die spd
plötzlich also so die arbeitszeit
ausweiten bildet
also von daher also das bedeutet
umgekehrt ein lohn unterstellt wird mit
24 euro in der stunde also das heißt
solchen arbeitnehmern der 24 euro in der
stunde verdient in trautmann nicht zu
über seine arbeitszeit auch richtig
dementsprechend buch zu führen also das
ist ein misstrauen gegenüber den
arbeitnehmern und ist ein misstrauen
letztendlich gegen die arbeitgeber da
sollte man auch darüber nachdenken
ein drittes ein drittes wichtigkeit
seines detail zeit fall ist danke
ausdrücklich der frau kollegin müller
gemmeke dass sie diese auch mit
dargestellt hat aber ihr die fdp
kollegen die bleiben hier zu kurz denn
die teilzeit falle die besteht wir haben
zwar die angleichung bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen möglich
unterstützen wir es gar keine frage aber
dann muss zum beispiel
121 oder
522 euro die gesamten 520
22 euro dann voll versteuern und das ist
die spiele ja siehe die schwelle was sie
dann bedeutet dass niemand in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung geht und das sollte die
fdp nachdenken darüber und nicht der
politischen ansprüche weiter zu erhöhen
und es bleiben also besitzer also
traunik contact ich gehe also das wird
sozusagen also zu reduzieren ist euer
kollegen
jonas stockinger war hier kaum zu
stoppen und auch nicht zu stoppen ist
die nächste und letzte rednerin jasmin
fahimi rainer hoffmann ist der
dgb-vorsitzende er wird im mai in den
ruhestand treten und sie ist ausgeschaut
als erste frau überhaupt
chefin des deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes
zu werden im mai wird gewählt an ihrer
wahl gibt es keinen zweifel vielleicht
ist es heute tatsächlich hier ihre
letzte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
verehrte zuschauerinnen und zuschauer an
den monitoren in drei tagen begehen wir
den ersten mal den tag der arbeit ein
tag an dem es darum geht für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen zu demonstrieren und
erfolge zu feiern und deswegen ist es
ein großartiges zeichen dass heute hier
von diesem deutschen bundestag ausgeht
endlich führen wir den mindestlohn von
zwölf euro in deutschland ein
versprochen gehalten
sage aber auch eine entscheidung die
überfällig ist und die umstände warum
wir es nicht schon haben tun können die
sind allseits bekannt sie sitzen heute
in der opposition
und es ist auch ein grund dafür warum
sie heute in der opposition sitzen denn
die menschen die wissen ganz genau dass
der mindestlohn von 12 euro eine
politische note wer ist eine politische
notwehr reaktion auf schwindende
tarifbindung weil zu viele arbeitgeber
einfach glauben dass die lohnfindung auf
dem freien markt stattzufinden hätte
also im lohndumping wettbewerb und genau
das wollen wir abstellen faire löhne
faire löhne entstehen nur in
tarifverhandlungen und wer sich denen
entzieht muss sich nicht wundern wenn
die politik eingreift denn tatsache ist
vielmehr so wie das hier schon viele
dargestellt haben das über sechs
millionen beschäftigte in deutschland
davon profitieren werden insbesondere in
ostdeutschland insbesondere frauen das
ist gut so und es ist zugleich traurig
traurig dass so viele menschen heute
immer noch einer beschäftigung nachgehen
müssen die nicht
ansatzweise existenzsichernd ist mit
allen konsequenzen auch für die armut im
alter das einzige argument das immer
noch dagegen ins feld geführt wird ist
die behauptung das widerspräche der
tarifautonomie deswegen noch mal zur
erklärung für alle die garantierte
tarifautonomie in unserem land ist die
anerkennung autonome ausgestaltung der
sozialpartnerschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
die intention des gesetzgebers war und
ist klar nämlich das recht der
eigenständigen regelung der arbeits und
wirtschaftsbedingungen durch
tarifverträge es ist nicht das recht auf
verweigerung es ist der auftrag zur
regelung wer sich also hört sich also
der tarifautonomie wer sich auf die
tarifautonomie bezieht um eben diesen
auftrag abzulehnen
entschuldigen sie bitte aber der vergeht
sich einem grundverständnis in der
grundarchitektur unserer sozialen
marktwirtschaft
deswegen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist die einführung des mindestlohns auch
ein klares zeichen an die wirtschaft
schafft mehr tarifbindung die zweite
gute nachricht des tages ist genau das
tut es auch wir haben das schon bei der
einführung 2015 erlebt wo eben ist ein
fahrstuhl effekt gegeben hat auch für
lohngruppen kurz oberhalb des
mindestlohns sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe frau präsidentin jetzt
entschuldigung da dies mit nennenswerter
wahrscheinlichkeit meine letzte rede im
deutschen bundestag sein könnte lassen
sie mich noch ein paar kurze anmerkungen
wache ich hoffe dass dieses haus stets
sich daran erinnert dass eben die
sozialpartnerschaft quasi mit
verfassungsrang die geschicke dieses
landes maßgeblich mitgestaltet hat eine
der lehren auf die schlechten der
weimarer republik war es dass es ohne
sozialen frieden keine äußeren frieden
gibt keinen dauerhaften wohlstand und
keine innovative wirtschaft es war hans
böckler 1951 der in den verhandlungen
mit dem mit der damaligen regierung von
konrad adenauer das montan
mitbestimmungsgesetz durchgesetzt und
damit die grundlage dafür geschaffen hat
dass arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
diesem land keine bittsteller sind weder
gegenüber dem staat noch gegenüber der
wirtschaft dass sie mitbestimmungsrechte
haben sowohl in der aufsicht des der der
unternehmen bei der arbeit im betrieb
und eben bezüglich ihrer
arbeitsbedingungen samt löhne und
gehälter in tarifverträgen diese dinge
sind untrennbar miteinander verbunden
und sie müssen auch von diesem haus
bitte immer wieder neu verteidigt und
weiterentwickelt werden wenn es gelingen
soll wenn friede freiheit und
gerechtigkeit über alle veränderungen
und krisen hinweg gelingen soll
liebe präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren es
gibt erste und letzte momente die einem
vor augen führen was es heißt
parlamentarierin zu sein die einem auch
manchmal die knie weich werden lassen
egal wie gut man ist das erste mal in
diesem saal in dem otto wels die ehre
der weimarer republik verteidigt hat das
war mein erster moment und heute das
letzte mal an diesem pulk von wo ich
mich bei ihnen verabschiede in schweren
zeiten dieses landes und ihnen die worte
von eines themen reden gerne in
erinnerung rufen möchte weisheit macht
und wissen haben ein geheimnis es ist
die demut ich bedanke mich recht
herzlich für die zusammenarbeit
fraktionsübergreifend wünsche ihnen
alles gute weiterhin viel tatkraft und
mut ich freue mich darauf an anderer
stelle mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten
blick auf
das war wohl die letzte rede von jasmin
fehmi die spd-abgeordnete wird als erste
frau überhaupt voraussichtlich im mai
zur dgb chefin gewählt werden rainer
hoffmann ersetzen
in altersruhestand geht's viel applaus
hier von den koalitionsfraktionen
keiner ahnt bei der opposition doch
dabei der linken sehe ich anders